so the contraceptive pill is the first
transhumanist technology it's the first
major widespread
um social you know biomedical
Intervention which aims not at fixing
something which has gone wrong with
normal Health but upgrading normal you
know in line with what people want it's
impossible to separate Liberation from
commodification and the same goes as
well for the fertility industry which is
to say the moment the moment in theory I
can control my fertility it becomes
theoretically possible to commodify my
fertility I've argued that the
Technologies which enable us to flatten
the differences between the Sexes
fundamentally you know beginning with
the pill and abortion are in logical
continuity with the Technologies now
being employed by by transgender
identified people to Flat to become as
they see it their true selves and the
fundamental difficulty we have at the
moment is that these a lot of these
policies are being driven by Elite women
who simply don't see the downsides
because they just never they they're
less likely to encounter them there's a
lot of women who would actually disagree
with you who say look I live in a
society which is Freer than ever I have
more Choice than ever before I can pick
a wide range of careers I can choose
when it when I want to have a child
surely these are all positive things man
yes but they're not without cost
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People a terrific get
and returning guest today is a writer
and the author of the upcoming book in
fact it's out already here in the UK
it's called feminism against progress
which is exactly the kind of feminism we
like on this show Mary Harrington
welcome back to trigonometry thank you
for having me again yeah it's a real
pleasure to have you on how have you
been there you've been writing this book
for a while
uh yeah I've been well I'm
it's been a very strange sort of Hiatus
for me because the book obviously I've
finished writing writing late last year
and then there's this period where you
go through it and you check to make sure
you know people tell you off for your
sloppy footnoting and um and it goes
through the whole post-production
process and then you just have to wait
and that's where I've been for a little
while and it's a bit like the point
where I ran out of things to revise at
University and then it was just waiting
for finals so that's about where I am at
the moment just waiting waiting for the
for the other shoe to drop well having
read the book uh we can say that you've
passed
but but uh for more interestingly of
course our audience tell us uh what is
the central case because last time we
had you on the show we talked about this
idea you said you don't believe in
progress well I still don't believe in
progress but now you also don't believe
you know you you've you want feminism
that's against it well I the central
thesis of the book is that much of what
we understand as feminism is less an
effect of endless moral Improvement
towards some kind of Imagine future
heaven on Earth as as a side effect of
technology and specifically of women's
responses to changes in how we live
together as a consequence of
technological advancements
um and you can and so the book traces
the the development you know traces
women's responses to firstly Industrial
Revolution and then more importantly
from the point of view of my case
against progress of the the what I think
what I call the cyborg Revolution which
is much more recent and is is really
everything which has come since the
contraceptive and the digital
Revolutions in the mid-20th century and
I argue that at that point
um a progress which previously seemed to
be delivering never-ending dividends of
more freedom and more more good things
for everybody and particularly for women
has now increasingly turned against
women and is delivering not just
diminishing returns but actively making
life worse for everyone all women except
an increasingly a shrinking Elite well
before we we get into the the way that
that is making things worse you
mentioned the the response to Industrial
Revolution and so on give us a quick run
through of the some of the changes the
technology because I think the in the
modern Consciousness people don't think
think about it at all like they think
that women's rights were achieved in the
way that we currently conceive of them
purely through campaigning protesting
you know throwing yourself in front of
horses that sort of thing right so
what's actually happened throughout
history give us a brief overview what I
that this was this part of the story was
the the result of me doing a deep dive
into first wave feminism which doesn't
really get much of a look in in terms of
sort of school
school history lessons if you like you
know apart from the suffragettes you
know everyone knows that you know there
was the one who threw herself under a
horse and you know they jumped up and
down and said votes for women but people
don't really talk about the the century
or so of women's women's activism and
Whitney arguments over the relations
between men and women and really a
feminism prior to that and there was an
awful there was a lot of it and really
people people were intensely preoccupied
from the Industrial Revolution onward
with the the changing roles of men and
women and how families should be formed
and how men and women should relate to
one another because the Industrial
Revolution changed that radically
um it had a you know profound effects um
really
for the fundamental reason that work no
longer happened for a growing number of
people in the way that it had done for a
very long period of time so if in the
Middle Ages most work happened in the
home you know and both sexes worked
um you know it's a it's a mistake to
imagine that women only women only
entered and entered the workplace or
women only worked from the mid the mid
20th century onward in fact that so that
pretty much has it backwards almost all
women apart from very very very
aristocratic ones worked in Pre in
pre-modern England because most work
happened in farm houses and in Artisan
in the house in what what historians
call a productive household so that
might have been a couple and possibly
extended family members as well
um producing subsistence Goods for the
family possibly producing Artisan goods
for sale possibly you know producing
goods for for use within the family
um so in a in a farm in a Farmstead
situation that might be the men
producing raw materials and the women
producing processing those into Fabric
or food or you know other Goods for the
family and a huge amount of that just
happened in the home and women who were
mothers would have done that with kids
underfoot and the kids would have worked
would have chipped in as well the moment
they were old enough to do it so that's
the sort of pre-modern template for a
productive household but when you think
about what happens when when so much of
that work industrializes
um it changed things radically and
particularly for women
um I've taken the example of textile
making because for tens of thousands of
years prior to the Industrial Revolution
that was always women's work and there
are there are historians who've looked
at textile making you know throughout
the Millennia and argued that it's
historically been women's work because
it can be you know you can raise a loom
off the ground so it doesn't get your
baby doesn't eat it um you know it can
it's semi-interruptible work you know if
you're you're flinging a shuttle back
and forth you know you can stop because
the baby's about to climb into the fire
or whatever
if you you know and and it's social as
well so you know you're not just stuck
at home on your own with a baby so it's
it works you know it makes sense for it
makes sense for you if you've got kids
underfoot for women to be doing that but
now if you think about what happens in
with industrialization
um suddenly textile making you know the
spinning and the weaving are both done
by via heavy
um expensive industrial Machinery which
has to be centralized in a factory so
instead of making textiles in the home
suddenly even if even if you're a woman
and you want to go on textile making you
know you've got you've got this decision
to face you know if you you have a
breastfed baby at home and suddenly you
have to go you have to travel some
distance away and work a 12 hour shift
in a factory what do you do
you know it's a problem that you never
had to face before
um so this is just one way of
illustrating the fact that work and the
home separated in a way which actually
reduced women's agency at the beginning
of the Industrial Revolution and it's in
a sort of common kind of Pop feminist
idea is that women were radically
disempowered until feminism came along
and saved us all
um at the beginning and it sort of what
some distance into the modern era but
I've argued that actually relative to in
some respects the Medieval Era and women
actually lost agency with
industrialization and everything that
followed in terms of feminist activism
has been in response to that radical
disempowerment that happened with
industrial modernity
so and that then and and looking at the
19th century that took two distinctive
forms um on on the one hand you know the
world there were women who whose
activities at home were now just
confined to spending spending money and
looking after kids who argued that no no
actually this the work of the home is
good actually and we need to make sure
it's still valued and it's not it's not
in treated as second class and this was
the so-called Cult of Domesticity so you
have even as a proliferation of women's
magazines essentially most of which are
focused on bigging up the domestic work
that women do at home and feminist
historians have often often frame this
as a kind of false consciousness you
know parroting parroting the tropes of
patriarchy in order to accustom women to
their subjugation but another way of
looking at it might be that you know
these are women who recognize that
actually caring for children and the
work of the home and you know create you
know defending a space outside the
marketplace isn't is important and the
stuff that can't be done within the
market which still matters and we're
trying to make the case for actually
that being that being important and
valuable so in a sense it was it was a
kind of proto-maternal feminism that's
going on in The quote-unquote Cult of
Domesticity and then against that you've
got women who who say no actually you
know we don't want this domestic life we
want to enter the market on the same
terms as men we want to be able to go
out into the workplaces where some of
the work is now stuff we can do you know
I want I want a shot at being a
barrister or a doctor
and these tended to be more sort of
upper Bourgeois women
um and so so you have this sort of
bifurcation of you know where there are
women who push for greater valorization
of care and then there are women who
push for women to have personhood in
yeah understood as being an atomized
Market participant on the same terms as
men and these these These are the the
two polls of
um pre-cyborg feminism which I think of
as feminism proper
um which is the the the feminism of
freedom and the feminism of care and
there's a huge range of views within
within those two poles you know and the
back and forth between them and the
negotiation and trying to find a a
healthy balance between freedom and the
needs of dependence is I think probably
the the best characterization you can
give of what feminism looked like up
until the cyborg Revolution
I'm sure we will there's also the sexual
Revolution to consider which we kind of
see if that is disciples
because I thought the cyborg Revolution
was going to be slightly more recent but
anyway tell us about the cyborgs well I
mean I've this is this isn't actually
this is a I've made the case more
starkly since since I finished writing
feminism against progress but I realized
actually the pithiest way I can I can
say this is to make the claim that the
contraceptive pill is the first
transhumanist technology
and by that I mean it's the first tech
it's the first major widespread
um social you know biomedical
Intervention which aims not at fixing
something which has gone wrong with
normal Health but upgrading normal you
know in line with what people want I
mean if you think about what what
contraceptive pill does I mean it
actually interrupts normal healthy
fertility in the interests of
um essentially personal freedom
um and and in that's in in that sense
it's it's fundamental it's a radically
different Paradigm For What by
biomedical Technologies can and should
do
um and that that obviously as we know
was legalized and spread like wildfire
in the 1960s
um and downstream Downstream of that um
came a whole load of other
technological transformation you know
we're a good a good way further down
down the path that that started but my
my yeah my argument is that you know we
became cyborgs and women became cyborgs
arguably ahead of men
um at the point where we accepted um
transhumanist medicine as a as a basic
enabling condition for women's
participation in society which really
began in the 1960s wow I mean
that's a really really good way of
putting it
my question to you is this what does
feminism now mean Mary
because we've got first second third I
mean we've got more waves in the
Mediterranean Sea so what does it
actually mean when when we use this word
because I think that's important
when we have this discussion well it
really depends who you ask
um I mean there are
I would if you want to take the sort of
consensus view of what I think of as
magazine feminism if you know the the
kind of Pop version that comes out in in
articles about who you should or
shouldn't date and why yeah that kind of
the sort of Jezebel feminism
um the I would say the broad consensus
is probably that
um feminism is actually I'm just going
to quote the onion at you here feminism
is anything a woman does
um that's the to put it very crudely you
know and and really this this also is
Downstream of the cyborg Revolution
because it's I've argued that the
arrival of the pill and particularly
with the the inevitable consequence of
the arrival of the pill which was the
legalization of abortion
um the feminism of freedom
decisively defeated the feminism of care
um because I'm so sorry to interrupt and
also I don't want to interfere with
Francis line of questioning but I'm
curious I I think I know why you say
that the legalization of abortion as a
consequence of the pill is it just like
a more advanced version of the same
thing essentially is that what you're
saying why is legalization of abortion a
consequences well yeah um people when
they campaign first for the pill the The
Hope was that there would be as a result
of the pill there would be fewer
accidental pregnancies and therefore you
know it would it would make you know
women's reproductive choices much more
within women's control but what happened
in practice was well the absolute number
of accidental pregnancies went up not
down and that was because there was just
so much more casual sex happening
because it didn't it radically moved the
goal posts for what you could or
couldn't do
um and and it's only mostly effective
it's not 100 effective so there was
still enough oops pregnancies despite
more yeah you know the the the rate of
accidental pregnancy went down but there
was so much more sex happening that the
absolute number went up and at that
point it created an inevitable ratchet
towards saying what are we going to do
about all these accidental pregnancies
because then it was very difficult to
put back in the box I mean it was pretty
much impossible to put it back in the
box so people are saying well well I
have the pill now and everybody's got
the pill and so they're all at it like
rabbits and you know we can't we can't
stop this now so you know we have to do
something about you know this is
obviously not a tenable situation you
know women are you know bleeding out in
Alleyways with coat hangers up them and
you know this is horrendous we've got to
do something because they you know that
they'd open Pandora's Box and so many of
the the very strict social controls
which had which had previously
um obtained around premarital sex were
beginning to Fall Away
and you know the case became very
compelling to legalize abortion but of
course once you do that
um you're saying that that women's
autonomy
um is fun to be in women's autonomy is
that much more important than the needs
of a dependent and it doesn't really get
much more dependent than an unborn baby
that's you know can't survive outside
its mother's body
um that you know that you can you can
end the end the potential life of the
dependent in order to safeguard the
freedom yeah and so so at that point the
the feminism of freedom and the feminism
care of care collided and and and you
know history history tells us which one
won and that's the world we've been
living ever since and so I think that's
the long answer Francis to your question
of what is feminism
um it's a it's the feminism as we
understand it today in its mainstream
sense is a Doctrine which argues that we
can and should use technology in EV you
know to the fullest extent possible to
flatten the differences between the
Sexes and what's wrong with them even at
the even at the expense of unborn lives
and but what's wrong with it I think
there's a lot of women who would
actually disagree with you who say look
I live in a society which is Freer than
ever I have more Choice than ever before
I can pick a wide range of careers I can
choose when it when I want to have a
child
surely these are all positive things man
yes but they're not without cost I I
entirely agree with you that these are
all positives but they're not cost free
I think and that's that's really what so
so that that gets us to the end of part
one and parts Part Two really is about
some of the undercounted costs of the
victory of
freedom of a care when it comes or
rather Tech enabled Freedom over care in
the domain of feminism and so I've
looked at I've looked at the war it's
been waging on our relationship on the
relations between men and women
um on the war it's been waging on the
relations between mothers and babies and
finally the war it wages on our
relationship with our own bodies
bless those out for us please okay so
the wrong turn of phrase war on
relationships
um let's think how do I characterize
this
the point at which
um
you you can use technology to flatten
the difference between the Sexes is the
point at which sex leaves the domain of
um
management by social social norms and
becomes something which is theoretically
free it becomes it becomes private so I
mean let me let me back up a little bit
so if you if you imagine I'm it's it's
1910 you know I'm I'm female you know
I'm I'm a young woman I get horny like
like all humans do whereas in
adolescence
um there are very very you know my mum
tells me never be never be seen alone
with a guy you know they they can get
ideas you know and you're warned at all
you know and you're supervised carefully
by your aunties and your mum and and
this is all with a very pragmatic intent
um and it might seem unfair because guys
don't get this level of supervision and
constraint but they so there's a very
practical intent behind it which is that
um you know if I get Knocked Up by
mistake which with somebody who then
just you know disappears on me
um it's a problem you know it's not just
a problem for me um it's a problem for
everybody in my immediate family and
it's a problem for wider Society so
whether or not it's unfair the basic
asymmetry between the reproductive roles
of men and women
um just forces you know a pragmatic
response to that at scale you know in
order to manage the the challenge posed
to everybody in general by by babies by
unplanned babies um
so there's this there's this intense
social pressure from all directions
which is aimed at funneling couples into
something like functional functional
diets
which can raise children together
because it's just it's just the result
is just less messy when you do it
um then you then you then you add the
pill into the mix um all of a sudden all
of those rules are theoretically
weightless you don't need them anymore
because I can just I can I can just take
this medicine
um which means that I can have as much
sex as I want
um but the the the thesis I've I've
Advanced for what happens at that point
is that when in theory you know my
sexuality is now my private domain but
what happens at that point isn't just a
dividend of Freedom
um but the the market also moves into
that space because once once something
belongs just to me in theory I can buy
or sell it as I see fit and really the
the governing the the Common Thread to
the these various Wars on relationships
is the way that Technologies the the
intervention of Technologies into our
bodies you know seems to privatize the
different facets of our bodies whether
that's our our fertility our our
sexuality or or even really our
embodiment itself but in practice what
happens then is that that becomes
commodified so so in the context of sex
um the the Empire you know the the porn
industry and the sex industry began to
mushroom the moment the the moment those
those constraints on sex went away
um I mean you know the prostitution
isn't called the world's oldest industry
for nothing you know it's always been
there but but it absolutely boomed In
from from the 60s onwards I mean and he
Hugh Hefner's um Playboy and Playboy
clubs
um appeared the same year as the pill
was legalized um and by the 1970s you
know radical feminists were protesting
against the the in the endemic and
increasingly violent and degrading
nature of pornography which was now just
being marketed pretty much openly
because sexuality was privatized you
know suddenly there was this libertarian
argument for letting women do whatever
they wanted with their bodies now in
practice if you speak to a survivor of
the the sex or the porn Industries
they'll tell you that in fact there's a
great deal more coercion that goes into
that than than the libertarian arguments
might like might like to believe but but
but fundamentally you know the the this
is the pattern that I wanted to to
sketch at is the this that it's
impossible it's impossible to separate
Liberation from commodification and the
same goes as well for the fertility
industry which is to say the moment the
moment in in theory I can control my
fertility it becomes theoretically
possible to commodify my fertility so if
you fast forward a number of decades on
from the arrival of the pill we're a
long way down that path I mean we have
we have young women who've been rendered
infertile by selling their eggs in order
to pay for college tuition
um you know we have the entire I'm sure
you saw the headlines during when the
war in Ukraine began of these these
Ukrainian surrogates it's a it's a big
industry over there yeah impoverished
young women in the Ukraine who
essentially who essentially rent their
wounds to wealthy westerners who don't
who either don't want to gestate
themselves or you know don't have a
uterus between them or you know for
whatever reason and all these all these
babies all who by the way of postponed
having children to the point where
they're physically and precisely because
of the society because of yeah yeah
precisely because of that
um and all these babies you know lined
up in rows and bomb shelters without
your motherless babies essentially yeah
and their their gestational surrogates
have left and then they're just sort of
being cared for on this kind of
semi-factory conditions by by a couple
of nurses with the bombs falling
overhead you know just astonishingly
dystopian images which is which is again
what what you begin to see once you
privatize
um something which was previously
governed by social norms and finally you
know in the same context I've argued
that the Technologies which enable us to
flatten the differences between the
Sexes fundamentally you know beginning
with the pill and abortion are in
logical continuity with the Technologies
now being employed by by transgender
identified people to Flat to become as
they see it their true selves you know
in ways which use technology to flatten
the differences between the Sexes or to
remodel remodel secondary sex
characteristics in line with in line
with their preferred felt sense of self
so so really I mean I'm very
straightforwardly I'm arguing that you
you couldn't have you couldn't have
trans people without the pill and
abortion and that without in and any
coherent critique of trans identity has
to begin with a coherent critique of
what the pill does
um because fundamentally if you're going
to say women are allowed to emancipate
ourselves by by getting rid of what
makes us by flat using technology to
flatten what makes us distinctively
female why shouldn't other people become
more fully themselves using technology
is to flatten what make them
distinctively themselves you know what
why shouldn't we just take that a little
bit further and just remodel ourselves
as we see fit you know if you're if if
you're if you're bought into the cyborg
feminist Paradigm you know trans
activism is just is absolutely in
logical continuity with it and and I
would I would go as far as to say that
the the cyborg feminist argument is is
more coherent so you know quite a lot
more coherent than those radical those
gender critical ones which say we should
have the pill and abortion but we can't
we can't have trans activism because
we're gonna we're gonna flatten the
second we're going to flatten
reproductive characteristics of women
but wait no not like that
it doesn't make sense so
is that the reason Mary these cyborg
feminists are in your in the words you
use are pro porn sex workers work as a
mantra that they like to say Yep they're
Pro uh surrogacy and they're pro-trans
and it stems right the way back to this
side it's all it's all entirely coherent
it's it's it would make no sense at all
to be for some for some of those things
and against some of the others it all it
all goes back to
um the the definitive defeat of the
feminism of care about the feminism of
Freedom you know if we're allowed to use
technology to to remodel our bodies as
we see fit then that just goes all and
work and when we invite the market into
ourselves as a side effect of
um the the Emancipation that produces
then you just have to follow that all
the way down the rabbit hole but Mary
then why is it with these feminists when
they see the negative effects of their
arguments for instance we know that sex
work is not good for women we just know
it isn't I mean people will try and
dress this up and they'll try and give
you you know arguments but if we no one
would want their daughter to participate
in the sex industry that is pretty much
obvious
if we look at abortion again no one
would want their child or very few
people who want their child to have an
abortion and thirdly
as we've seen with the case of Isla
Bryson the end game for the transgender
ideology is profoundly negative to women
rapists and female prisons
at what point does this break and do
people start to wake up
and are we actually seeing that at the
moment well I think people are breaking
and people are waking up but one of the
difficulties is or or what one of the
one of the tensions is
what is
is social class fundamentally
um
and by that I mean all women all women
are not the same I mean you can talk
about you can talk about something being
universally in women's interests but I'm
I'm fundamentally my feminism is
anti-universalist and by that I mean I
think you can talk you can talk
concretely about women's interests and
you can care about women's interests but
the same policy could be pro-women and
anti-women depending on the context
um and though the fundamental difficulty
we have at the moment is that these a
lot of these policies are being driven
by Elite women who simply don't see the
downsides because they just never they
they're less likely to encounter them so
I mean if you think about I forget the
names of the the Scottish members of
parliament who've been cheerleading for
for gender for gender self-declaration
recently but there are lots of them you
know penny more daunt has been a big
flag waiver for that in the United
Kingdom and and these These are women
who likely grew up in fairly comfortable
Bourgeois homes because though those are
the people who become politicians you
know they've been to universities
surrounded by men who are mostly
reasonably well behaved in relative to
the way some can behave you know they've
they mostly socialize in situations
where men are not routinely violent or
unpredictable or just outright dangerous
and and they and I think it's possible
if you've just been sheltered in that
way simply not to be able to imagine
just how depraved some people can be
it's just that they're just not able to
picture it and therefore it's a
fundamental blind spot that's that it
simply does it simply refuses for
whatever reason to grow up with simply
refuses to grasp the fact that
bad act really really really bad actors
exist
um and and yeah and and the and the
problem is that pushing for the
effectively the abolition of sex in law
is in the interests of this of the upper
of uppercrust women you know if you're
if you're a knowledge class worker which
is to say you're a barrister or you're a
solicitor or an accountant or something
it is not in your class interests for
for there to be a serious conversation
going on which says men and women are
different
you know it's not it's you know because
professionally at work you can see how
that could very easily become you know
are you going to perform less well in
your spreadsheet jockeying job you're
going to end up making the coffees again
right exactly exactly you know red flag
you know alarm Bells start going off in
your head when people start talking
about how men and women are different
and and frankly if you're a barrister or
an accountant you probably don't see it
I mean there's no earthly reason why I
shouldn't be uh Better or Worse
Barrister than some guy apart from the
fact that I'd be terrible but that's
that's my first that's my personality
that's just I'm yeah I'm basically
unemployable in that way but that's
that's nothing to do with my sex that's
my bad attitude yeah I find it but yeah
I mean you understand the point I'm
making and also there's another way
these women benefit because if if we are
in a situation as you described where
there are certain things that have
become commodified well if you want to
be a barrister and you want to have a
child at 45 and have a Ukrainian it's
again it's in your interest and you've
got money to pay for a Ukrainian
surrogate that's fine I mean going down
a slightly darker past if you want to
you know if your husband's using
prostitutes that's that's fine you know
what's the problem right and in fact it
may be better for your marriage yeah so
it's it's not in your class interests if
you're if you're a barrister or an
accountant to to go very far down the
rabbit hole of how different men and
women are and it's not a coincidence
that the highest rates of support for
Trans rights are among the most educated
women
um it's it's very obviously in in those
women's interests to believe that the
Sexes are fundamentally the same apart
from some trivial differences of genital
topography you know because that's that
that that works for you from a
professional point of view but if you're
a bin man or you're married to a bin man
you know the sex differences are obvious
you know nobody's campaigning for a 50
50 representation of the sexes in waste
collection or you know or working on an
oil rig I mean for very obvious reasons
you know men women are different you
know you know fun you know the in terms
of muscle mass and physiological you
know
I mean you watch those guys go they move
they move and it's physically arduous
work I don't think most women will last
10 minutes because we're just not
physically as strong you know which is
fine we have other talents but but the
point is
that once you start taking apart how
much sex matters you can see very
quickly that it's it's a question of
class yes it's fundamentally women uh
have a particular worldview that is
shaped by their circumstances which they
could perfectly be forgiven by the way
because people act in their own
interests they understand them
so so we are in the situation where as
in many other things I think we'd agree
the there is a certain Elite view of how
things ought to be that is not in the
interest of the majority is that fair to
say yes I would say that's accurate so
you're not a tech determinist we
discussed this on the way here so I said
to you well if technology is you know
driving all of this what's the point of
writing a book about the feminism
against progress but your point is
you're not a determinist and you think
culture matters I think culture matters
I mean it's obvious that culture matters
because otherwise everywhere in the
world would have the same level of
Economic Development and technological
advancement and they don't
and the only other the only obvious
explanation for that
um is I mean geography matters obviously
geography but also culture geography
shapes culture I mean this is what
people don't say about Russia the reason
Russians either way they are is because
it's pretty hard to survive in that kind
of have you seen Russia
exactly and so the question inevitably
is
what do we do about this what do we do
about this well the arguments my
argument is that it doesn't follow that
just because
many knowledge class women unthinkingly
adopt these positions which are having a
number of heavily negative Downstream
effects that we should necessarily that
we just have to you know this is beyond
precisely my point is I I belong to that
class you know I'm laptop class I work
remotely I write for a living you know
this in I I belong to you know I'm a
class traitor in even making these
arguments but but that that in itself is
necessary that is that in itself is
testimony to the fact that it's you
don't you know people are not robots you
know we're not we're not determined
we're not over determined by our by our
economic circumstances and it's possible
to take different views and there are
plenty there are other in growing
numbers of other uh knowledge class
women like me who look around and think
no actually this isn't this this is this
isn't good this is this is making things
worse for everybody this is this is
profoundly wrong for
for a number of a whole host of reasons
and and the the backlash is coming
coming back up the food chain and it's
and it's heading for me and it's heading
for my daughters and really it's heading
for all of us and so what are we going
to do about it which is which is your
question I mean because I don't hear you
or Louise Perry who I imagine is one of
the people you referred to as these very
bright women who are looking at these
issues with the uh with a focus on on
this side of it I don't hear you talking
about banning abortion I don't hear you
talking about reinstating gender roles
like what do we do well
I I've made a three-part case for some
things which I think would help and all
of which I think can and should be led
by women
the first of these is the case for
marriage
and this is this is really this is the
Duma case for marriage I suppose you
know if if base if essentially we're
facing um a sort of all-out War on
relationships
um one of one of the things I think you
know one of the first moves that men and
women really need to make is
towards rethinking what marriage means
in the context of the 21st century and
I've argued that that we need to step
away from this very individualized very
consumerist
um very
very picky under sort of high romantic
vision of marriage which is what it's
sort of degraded into in the context
where everybody is an individual
economic agent including women and and
try and try and move towards something
closer to the pre-modern understanding
of of marriage as a marriage as a
covenant rather than a contract and
marriage as the enabling condition for
life together on the basis that if the
world carries on getting worse as I
anticipate it well you know we're well
past Peak progress in my view as we
discussed last time I was here
um and I think for again for all but the
wealthiest
um life the future is looking like is
looking scarcer potentially more
volatile potentially more
more unstable for for a lot of people
and and if if men and women are going to
thrive together and if and if
fundamentally for women who are mothers
um it's it's an urgent feminist project
to try and rebuild a slightly more
stable society and the smallest possible
functioning unit of social stability is
marriage and we just need to rethink a
little bit what it means and I think I
think we need to start with what I I
coined the abolishing big Romance
which is to say the the idea that
marriage should always be about personal
gratification sometimes it has to be
about
um
it has to be about building forming a
household together and just keeping
things going and and and actually well
and really I mean if you're going to be
very reductive what I'm saying is
staying together for the kids is good
actually
and in most cases you know I mean I'd
make an exception for cases where where
a relationship is violent or outright
abusive but in most cases the numbers
suggest that you know where couples
where couples separating marriages which
weren't terrible they were just not
ecstatic those are the most disastrous
outcomes for children because because
actually it was good enough for them and
and my argument is that particularly now
we're out the other side of peak
progress you're making a big gamble
think assuming that the world is going
to remain stable enough for it to be
wise to continue going it on your own
and actually if we're going to have a
have even the remotest shot of
rebuilding some kind of functional
social stability out the other side of
total atomization it has to begin with
being willing to take the rough with the
smooth in your in your partnership and
just seeing that as the indissoluble
long-term thing you know for all but the
most extreme cases of challenge so
that's part one but part two is you know
that that's all very well
um but you know there's no point in
telling women to embrace a slightly more
pragmatic approach to marriage if
there's not to marry and and so part two
really has to be men thinking seriously
about you know the the feminist case for
letting men leaving men alone
well
well to to dig down into that a little
bit the argument I'm I'm arguing that
um there is in fact a precedent for the
incursion which is currently a foot into
women's single sex Spaces by transgender
identified men
males
and interesting demonetized thank you
so
I'll say that again just in case you do
want to cut it there's a precedent for
the current contest which is going on
over transgender identified males in
women's prisons and it was led by
feminists which is to say the The
all-out Assault on boys clubs which has
been well underway all the way through
the 20th century you know and I think
that one paradigmatic instant and it was
asymmetric as well you know you a
paradigmatic example of that is Boy
Scouts
um where scouting went went co-ed a long
time ago while Girl Guides remain single
sex and and or rather it remains single
sex until the point where
where trans activists insisted that
males could join the Girl Guides as long
as they said they were women I was all
female
um and but but I mean from from that
point of view you know what's happened
more recently in Girl Guides it just
mirrors something which happened a long
time ago in Scouts and I've made the
case that in fact there are aspects of
Single Sex male sociality which have
been lost and the and the biggest loss
has been to working-classmen
um who who for whom there haven't been
any corresponding benefits to outweigh
the loss and and I think it's it's
particular it's painful and striking
when you look at the rates of mental
psychic psychiatric distress and and
elevated rates of suicide you know and
other indicators of of distress that
they're absolutely the highest amongst
amongst working-class men and
particularly amongst men who are who are
divorced
um because without any with very limited
access to any kind of male sociality
which is become routinely the case in
the modern world you know men are
getting lonelier and the statistics bear
this out consistently
um pretty much the only social contact a
lot of men have is by their wives and if
they lose that there's really nothing
left you know and these are utterly
alienated men and the consequences of
that are there are there in the in the
statistics and it's pretty great
um
so
um so so that's that's one facet of it
which is which is you know if we're
but but I I've sort of taken that a
little bit bring back the gentleman's
club yeah exactly bring back the
Bullington but I mean you know I don't
really care about the Bullington to be
on you know that's that's a very that's
a very small subset of men what I do
what I can a great deal more about is is
though is those other clubs for ordinary
guys yeah
um which have just Fallen by the wayside
with the result that a lot of regular
guys are just lonely but more
importantly younger guys don't don't
receive the same level of mentorship
that they might otherwise have done from
older guys and it's very obvious to me
I'm not going to try and make the case
for you but it's very obvious to me that
women don't form men men form each other
and they do that in ways that don't are
opaque to me because I'm not one but
they do it you know in some some kind of
hierarchical fashion in all male groups
and older men tell younger men how to
behave and that's just how it works
right I mean it's there's a certain
amount of chest beating and kind of
monkey stuff that I don't really
understand but it it happens it's
necessary right you can see it you can
see it happening and the upshot of that
is is broadly in women's interests you
know watching you know being around it
while it's going on isn't Fun you know
and you just want to kind of not be
there when it's going on but the the net
effect is generally beneficial to women
because you you end up with men who sort
of more or less know how to behave well
this is what women often don't
understand is women can never civilize
men you first need other men to do it
and then a woman can Tinker at the edges
so I think one of an underpriced
downside of abolishing male Single Sex
spaces has been has been the attrition
of that kind of socialization of young
men you know and I don't think it's a
coincidence that we now have this sort
of proliferating class of basement
dwelling needs
um who are you know these miserable
alienated disaffected guys who spend
their time computer gaming and
interacting with one another on the
internet while lamenting their the
impossibility of getting a girlfriend
and fermenting their General bitterness
and hatred towards women who they whom
they blame you know not totally
unreasonably for some of their ills I
mean I don't I think I and I'm here I'm
on very dangerous ground because I I'd
like to make it very clear that I don't
endorse you know I don't endorse that
entire world view
but I do
I do think that if you listen to it
um
how do I how do I say this without just
having a blow up completely in my face
it's not exactly the I mean the these
things get expressed as the most
horrendous violent just deeply
unpleasant misogyny
um and which in turn feeds the kind of
hostility from women which you know and
that's a vicious cycle which goes round
and round it's really unpleasant and you
know I read every so often I dip into
these forums and I come out feeling like
I need to take a shower you know it's
not nice
um but I think you know the ins there's
just at the most minute grain of I have
some sympathy with these guys because
something has been lost
um and that you know they're not
they're not paying they're not being
taught how to behave by older guys and
some of that genuinely is Downstream of
you know the co-edification of social
life it really is
and some of that is Downstream of
feminist activism you know and you know
I'm not saying it's all the fault of
feminists that insoles are such deranged
just psychos that's that's really not
what I'm saying but there's a
there's a
there's a set of complex systems which
shifted in a way which has been very
harmful for everybody as a consequence
of making slightly too much stuff co-ed
I think that's what I'm trying to say
um and so I'm so the upshot of all of
that is I I think we should I think I
honestly think as the the reactionary
feminist
um starts on all of this is we have to
just care a little bit less
if men want to do their thing on their
own without us you know they just have
to not mind as much
um and a positive an important positive
consequence of this I think would be
that we might we'd have more of a leg to
stand on asking for men's help in
defending women's single sex spaces in
sports and prisons
um because I think as it stands
um you know basically we're saying you
can't have yours you can't have your
boys clubs but can you help us protect
our Girls Clubs and that you know and I
think not unreasonably there's a lot of
guys who are like you made your bed
ladies yeah you can lie in it now and
we're just going to be over here
laughing and I'm like you know that's a
that's a really stupid and short-sighted
kind of kind of you know Chardon Freida
to be enjoying because at the end of the
day you know the the cyborgs are coming
for all of us and they want to upgrade
your kids as well but I think actually
here um it's incumbent on it's incumbent
on feminists to give a little bit of
ground and so that so really I'm making
the reactionary feminist case for a bit
more a bit more constructive sexism you
know and for and actually for that to be
a two-way street and then there was a
third part was there oh yes um sorry
France yeah I just want to let Mary
she's hiding all the super dangerous
ideas yeah behind that sweet smile so
I'm I'm waiting uh for the third so far
you can you've been very you've been
dancing around on this very thin ice and
what is the final piece so so part part
three well I'm
I've argued so I've argued that we need
we we need to to Grant more serious
Central Central position to marriage
that we need to we we need to be
realistic about what it what it take
what it will take to create the kind of
men that you know we want to marry and
spend our lives with and the final piece
of that is that we need to give we need
to give sex back the seriousness that it
that it has
um and this this for me means the
feminist case against the pill
now I'm now I'm to be clear I'm not
making the argument for
for
um
taking legal measures against the
contraceptive pill because that's just
nowhere near the Overton window but but
I but but you'd like to
those are your words Francis not mine
um well what what I do think we can do
at this point is just lean a little bit
harder into something which is already
happening which is a female particularly
young gen Zed female backlash against
the pill
um and that's that's a phenomenon which
I've been tracking for some years
um
and I mean I was genuinely shocked to to
hear how the the her usage and
prescription of these really quite
mind-altering medicines has changed
since I was in in adolescence I mean
when I was when I was a teenager if you
went to your GP and said can you put me
on the pill you'd get them you'd get the
third degree about you know are you in a
steady relationship and you know X Y and
Z and you know is an appropriate
relationship and do we need to talk to
your parents and so on and now as far as
I can make out you know it's it's pretty
routine you know for GPS just to stick a
girl on the pill at about the age of 15
and that's just it and there's a there's
a book that came out last year I think
um is it called your your brain on the
pill or something anyway so it goes into
goes into just how radically
mind-altering the effects are of this of
this drug
um it changes it changes who you find
attractive it changes your your entire
hormonal cycle it changes your attitude
it can have major mental health
implications for young women whose
brains let's not forget are still
developing
um you know the the downstream you know
the the mental the psyche the psycho
psychoactive impact of this drug are
immense I mean I was on it briefly and
you know and and I stopped in my early
20s because I I just realized it was
making me fat and sexless and it's
low-key insane and I yeah I was just
like it's just not worth it you know
what what's the point of taking this
thing so I can have sex if I no longer
enjoy having sex what am I doing no I
think I'd rather just not not have sex
with men which is
um the solution which I adopted for a
number of years
um
so
these now were seeing a growing body of
young women who are saying I don't want
this and who are embracing you know less
less invasive you know less psychoactive
you know non-non-hormonal contraception
or just cycle tracking and my argument
is that this is just where we have to we
have to start here you know don't take
the pill don't encourage your friends to
take the pill you know reject reject
this idea that you can't be a person
unless you make sort of fun radically
psychoactive cyborg interventions in
your own body
um and and there are a number of things
that follow from that in terms of how
how you relate to other how you relate
to men and to your own sexuality and one
of them is that you know of necessity
you become choosier about who you sleep
with which from women's point of view
when you think about the amount when you
think about hookup culture is obviously
beneficial because one of the things
that women complain about is is ending
up ending basically consenting to
Loveless or degrading sex because they
just there's no obvious reason to say no
and you know if you if you sort of
neutered yourself sexually by by taking
this medicine you know being
this there sort of is no reason to say
no and and sometimes it might just seem
polite to put out
um which is a pretty pretty kind of grim
position to be in if you're a woman I
think
privately I think a lot of what a lot of
what flew under the metoo banner was
basically was basically this this
um there's young women who ascented to
things sort of out of politeness or
found themselves railroaded into sexual
encounters more or less out of
politeness that they couldn't say no to
or didn't have a robust enough reason to
say no to because they were already
contraceptive and if you're in a
situation where there's a meaningful
risk of pregnancy you know that's a
pretty solid motivation for saying no
actually no actually I'm not coming home
with you or no you know I'm now I'm here
you know I'm we're not doing this and
it's also you know for all for all but
the most you know straight up toe rag
it's a fairly robust reason as a guy to
not go there as well I feel like I'm not
on birth control and I'm not going to
use birth control you know you're not
you're
yeah it would it would take a fairly
serious a fairly serious scumbag anyway
so so it it reduces it reduces the
opportunity for bad sex which I think is
obviously in women's interests it also
makes sex better
um you know if you're as speaking as a
woman you know I'm not going to give you
Grizzly details and I'm too old and ugly
to you're talking about this stuff
anyway but if you're in tune with your
own Cycles you just it's just nicer you
you you know you know where you are and
you know there are certain kind of moods
go up and down over the course of a
month in ways which are interrupted if
you're on the pill
um and but but
I think one of the and and taking that a
little bit further
it's my view that
you can't have you can't have the
intensity and the mystery and the beauty
of a sexual encounter without the danger
um the fundamentally
we should we we take sex seriously or
have historically taken sex seriously
because there's the potential of
creating another human and once you take
that out of the picture
um something something strange happens
to the whole the entire field of
sexuality
um and again I can't prove this because
it's just a hunch but I'm willing to bet
that if if we didn't have if
contraception was no longer part of the
picture most of the cultural interest in
BDSM would go away you know most of the
choking most of the role-playing most of
the other ways that people look to put
the danger and the intensity in to a
sexual encounter which has been sort of
neutralized it's kind of vegan bacon
equivalent of of the sexual encounter
you know it's almost it's almost the
same but not quite and so you have to
add more hot sauce and that's where you
get all of these you know escalating
escalating levels of degrading
disgusting kind of Kink and
and extremities to people trying to add
the hot sauce back into something which
is fundamentally vegan bacon and you and
the the the obvious solution if you're
starting to get a newer to the hot sauce
is you know have the bacon but that
means you have the don't you put the
danger back in
and uh and I called this say I don't so
I don't think of this as a purity-based
argument against contraception you know
I think of it more as rewilding sex you
know and when you when you're in in an
ecological context when you talk about
rewilding that means sometimes
introducing apex predators back into an
environment I don't know if you've seen
that amazing viral video about what
happened when they when they introduced
wolves back into Yellowstone and and
they had all of these incredibly complex
effects on the ecosystem which ended up
with a river changing course because the
the the deer followed different patterns
and then other things happened in a
different pattern and eventually you
know things things writed themselves in
in a whole ecosystem which hadn't which
had been going slightly wrong before and
and it couldn't have happened without
the apex predator back in so I've sort
of I've used that as an as an analogy
for thinking about how we can correct
some of the things which have gone wrong
in our sexual ecology by by
reintroducing the the danger and the
intensity
um I mean this is a risky argument to be
making I feel like I'm on genuinely
heretical territory here but you know
essentially I'm making the pro sex case
against contraception Mary there's one
aspect of this of this discussion that
people at home will be watching
particularly the left Wingers
particularly the people who dare we say
it would identify associate going come
on Mary isn't this just what happens at
what they would call late stage
capitalism where jobs
don't make the money that they used to
inflation therefore people need to go
out to work therefore people need to go
out to work for longer we're doing
longer and longer hours it's no longer a
choice for women anymore as there was
for women 30 years ago to be able to
stay at home to have children where a
man can then go out to work and be able
to provide for a family
are we not ignoring that element of this
as well
well here just going back to what you
were saying about tech determinism and
my critique of technology and
Technologies
um I I say I'm not a tech determinist
and I'm also not not rabidly anti-all
Technologies
um I mean as a case in point
um I wouldn't be able to do what I do
um were it not for the fact that it's
possible to work remotely you know I
couldn't have I couldn't have juggled
writing around having a small child you
know if I wasn't able to work from home
and I think you know it's it you know
there are a lot of pitfalls that come
with
um particularly internet Technologies
but but there are also for for more
families for for quite a lot of families
There's an opportunity to bring work
back into the home which I think has a
has a huge a huge amount of potential
um and still
for many unrealized potential to make to
to create something a bit more like the
productive households that existed prior
to them to modernity
and I've given I've in the book I've
given the examples of two two families I
know who are already doing this
um who have some some kind of
um trade-based home activity combined
with a bit of homesteading combined with
a bit of remote digital work
um who have who have if you like a sort
of home-based portfolio
um economy
um which which is intentionally ordered
around raising kids
um and it you know I might be it of
course it's wildly optimistic to imagine
this this can never be the case for
everybody but I think it offers a
template for how we might be able to
rethink for for more people than is
currently the case you know the way the
way we're ordering family life because a
large part of of this is also the way we
identify ourselves when we when you ask
someone the first question you ask
someone really in our society is what
your name what is your name and what
what would you do and it's not really
sociable it's socially acceptable it's
seen almost as a bit weird for a woman
just to go I'm just I'm not I'm just a
mother look actually that's the most
important job in society yeah I've been
that Soldier and I can tell you that if
you when you go to a party and you're a
stay-at-home mum you know every
stay-at-home mum I've ever spoken to
knows what it's like when somebody says
what do you do and you tell them and
they're immediately looking over your
shoulder for someone more interesting to
talk to without fail and it gets to you
it gets you down
um it makes me really angry on behalf of
every every stay-at-home mum I know you
know who throws herself into really
important work and and just gets treated
as though they're just unimportant and
probably a bit thick
um it's it's grossly unjust but what I
but what I would also say about that is
that very few stay-at-home mums I know
just mum
um but what they what they do often do
is a whole range of other things which
are not immediately legible in Market
terms
and I think
part of the reason why Everything feels
so kind of empty and atomized you know
even even in a relatively Lively small
town like the one where I live
um is that a lot a lot of the mums who
used to run if they basically run the
fabric of Civic life are no longer doing
that because they're out at work
um and I think if we if it were if it
were possible or you know as as it
becomes possible for us to bring a bit
more of work back into the home there's
just a possibility that we might see
some some more of that liveliness and
that texture come back to in a
distributed way to small towns and local
communities you know as people re-claw
back a bit more of an opportunity to
work you know to do voluntaries to
balance we're doing voluntary stuff and
professional stuff in a more flexible
way you know from from from their own
homes or I think they also to be a
cultural shift as well because you know
as you know my wife and I just had a
baby my wife is looking after our son at
the moment uh I mean I always respected
my wife anyway but I respect her way
more now because I can see how
challenging but also amazing she she
isn't doing it right and I think part of
it is there's got to be a cultural shift
around that thing like
um you know the idea that you would just
stay home I mean what does that even
mean it's like saying well I'm just a
YouTube you know presenter what why do
you know what I mean
um do you think that's likely do you
think it's possible
I think probably what's more likely is
that we'll find ways of making a more
textured kind of
work home mixture more legible in Social
terms such that women who are mostly
mothers but who do a little bit of
remote something and a little and some
certain amount of Civic organizing you
know find find ways of telling their
stories which isn't quite isn't quite
this Stark split between being a mum and
being a something else does that make
sense that makes a lot of sense yeah
yeah and I and I I very deeply hope that
I think that will be a very very very
good outcome there's really though you
know it this idea that Trad wives that
there's anything tried about Trad wives
you know the city of the woman who just
keeps out who the woman who keeps house
and raises kids and so on and the the
idea there's anything trout about them
is actually has it all backwards the the
thing about Trad wives is that they're
actually very distinctively modern you
know they weren't a thing at all until
until work disappeared out of the home
into factories and offices and now that
it's theoretically possible for at least
some work to come back into the home you
know I I think I prefer to I prefer to
call not for Trad wives but trade wives
which is to say women who do stuff as
well as mumming
um and for and and actually for the
opportunity that that opens up for
fathers to be to be Pro to be
professionally active and also present
in their children's lives I mean my
husband works from home and I mean he's
out some of the time and he's traveling
some of the time but he's had he's had
an opportunity to be there
um for for our daughter's infancy in a
way which
yeah he was he was working he was doing
the commuter thing when she was a baby
and then you know basically chucked it
in to be to work from home running his
own business uh because he said he said
it's just like I I don't see her from
one week to the next and it made him so
miserable and I don't think he's alone I
think there's a lot there's a lot of
fathers who who take it for the team
essentially and who just feel pretty
much alienated from the from their wives
and children because they don't see them
from one end of the week to the next no
I think that's really important as well
and I've certainly found that I've
rearranged how I do this to a light
extent in order to be around a lot more
right right and I think yeah and so I
think there's a there's a compassionate
there's a
you know not not kind of radically
domesticated fatherhood where you know
dads have to be pretending to breastfeed
but just a slightly more flexible
template of of work and home coming back
together in in a slightly more textured
way which offers opportunities for women
to do some work whilst also being able
to be present for their babies but also
offers opportunities for dads to be
present more in a way which I think is
just healthier and more constructive
back to the Happy pre-industrial age we
go Mary yes yeah yes but with internet
Mary there's one thing that I I want to
finish by exploring that kind of because
there's a lot of time where I hear a
left-wing economic argument and I I
don't give it much credence
but in this case do they not have a
point that surely the the
end goal of capitalism is
commoditization of everything and
everyone and what we're seeing is a
commoditization of women's bodies Allah
only fans etc etc isn't this the logical
end game
yes
okay yeah
yes I mean my
I tend to get published I I read as a
conservative these days because I
question some
sacred cows of what has become the kind
of leftist Orthodoxy but fundamentally
the arguments in my book are but they're
all left arguments you know they're the
the my case my case against the
marketization of women's bodies my case
against cyborg theocracy as I've called
it as an anti-capitalist one you know
I'm I'm pushing back against the
marketization of everything I'm I'm
arguing for you know a reactionary
feminism as a way of clawing back some
space from the market and rebuilding
forms of solidarity you know hopefully
out the other side of the marketization
of everything you know as fundamentally
an anti-capitalist argument the women of
the World Unite well right well that
actually it's great and women it's
actually the opposite of that though
isn't it Mary because you're not arguing
against capitalism what you're arguing
for is for people to voluntarily make
decisions that they opt out of certain
things that capitalism I'm arguing for
for reclaiming our agency from a kind of
machine machineification of everybody
and you the and I'm arguing against the
idea that we should just inexorably
submit to the commodification of
ourselves even down to commodifying our
bodies well exactly and saying that we
have some agency and we don't have to
treat this as deterministic and we can
you know even if we're just doing that
at the level of family life you know
family life is as important as what you
do at scale in terms of political
activism and I think you know you know
my all of my work is is really about
emphasizing that you know the micro and
the macro are both equally important but
and I think I think you can treat you
can treat seat looking for ways to just
withdraw withdraw your labor essentially
um from from the marketization with
withdraw your body from commodification
I think that's a that it's an it's yeah
the reason I bring this point up about
capitalism which has quite often
critiques of capitalism end up with
people going you know we must overthrow
capitalism and women of the World Unite
or whatever it is but that isn't I just
don't see that as the path forward on
any of these things because it seems to
me on a lot of these issues uh the path
forward is not going to be legislation
the path forward is not going to be some
top-down instruction to people it's
going to be changing the culture which
is what we talked about earlier which is
a culture of people voluntarily deciding
to do things in a different way
voluntarily saying you know what being a
barrister actually isn't making me as
happy as as I wanted I want to have
children and do something else as you
you're talking about or I want to not do
this and do that and I voluntarily
choose to do this uh the same will
probably happen with technology I mean
there will be communities of people who
don't have give their children mobile
phones until they're 18 years old and
whatever that I think is probably much
more the path forward whereas the sort
of like we must end the capitalism type
of argument I just I don't see that
happening yeah I mean I think there are
there are a number of different facets
to it and you know and they I've focused
in the book much more on the question of
what you can do at the small scale than
than really what you know there's a I've
made a few points in the afterward for
what I think you know some some sketches
for what ought to happen at scale but
but fundamentally yes I think I've
argued that memes which is to say
culture matters as much as material
conditions and you know what material
conditions obviously shape what a
culture is but correspondingly the
culture the culture has a reciprocal
effect on material conditions and from
where we are right now if we just throw
up our hands and say well the technology
has us and there's nothing there's
nothing we can do then we might we might
as well throw in the towel and not and
you know I can I can pulp the book well
this one bugs me about all of this stuff
is like people forget about their own
role in their own lives like I was
talking to somebody on Twitter today
about this and they were like well it's
impossible for a woman now to stay at
home and be a mother well it's not
impossible you just don't like the
trade-offs there's a difference right
and so if you want to do certain things
if you want to have a family you can
have a family there are certain things
you're going to sacrifice in order to do
that and that that's why I think it's
really important to Hash this point out
because people still have agency people
still have the opportunity to choose to
live their life in a particular way and
that will have trade-offs and like all
aspects of life everything has
trade-offs right absolutely
um
and I think I mean it's it's fair to say
that you know if you're if you're going
to be if you're going to be the bow wave
of something quite new or you know
extremely retro depending on how you
look at it
um you know you're you're gonna be
you're going to be at the sharp end of
some of those trade-offs but
avant-gardests you know get followed by
more people you know once once a path
has been forged you know it's easier for
other people to follow and and you know
things things don't things are not that
fixed and social norms are not
absolutely set in stone and you know the
a wave of avant artists avant-garde
reactionaries now you know could be
could be the Vanguard for something
which becomes much more normal and much
more normalized in 20 years time but the
but somebody has to lead by example I
think is the point
um and so so you know if I'm if I'm
framing it as something quite radical at
this point I think that there's the
potential for
that there's the potential to to lead
the way in in
potentially huge and beneficial social
changes down the line but but for that
you really do have to have hope and you
know faced with the situation that we
currently have I think I think it's also
fair to say that you have to have some
courage if you're going to if you're
going to Buck the the prevailing Trends
quite as radically as as saying saying
saying yep yes to marriage yes to
benevolent sexism and no two
contraception which is very reductively
the case that I'm making if you're gonna
if you're gonna try and follow that path
you know you really are swimming against
the tide and that takes a measure of
Courage particularly if you say you're
doing it for feminist reasons Mary it's
been an absolute pleasure thank you so
much for coming on thank you thank you
it's been great we always end with the
final question which is what's one thing
we're not talking about as a society
that we really should be
yes
it's sort of hard to know where to begin
um I'm going to be slightly more as a
society I'm going to I'm not going to
focus on that what what I'll what I will
just say is I think the right is hopeful
the conservatives in particular are
hopelessly confused on technology
um and I think that's something which is
very under discussed particularly among
conservatives
um you know you have
you have you have guys on the one on the
one hand who are fantasizing about you
know going back to the Middle Ages and
then another bunch of guys who are
fantasizing about colonizing Mars
um and
you you've got the Tories in government
who are saying you know we want we want
the white heat of technology or whatever
they're calling it this this week and
then you know paying 30 000 a year to
whoever it is whose job it is to set
about you know making a road map for
ship for bringing shipbuilding back to
the UK and they're only going to pay
them you know less than you it was kind
of new new starters salary well you know
half of what that would be in a bank and
you just think no no none of this none
of this makes sense
um conservatives are just completely
confused about you know whether it makes
whether it's whether it makes sense to
you know dig everything up and you know
cut down the last Tree in pursuit of
economic growth
um or whether whether in fact that there
are there are things which are worth
conserving I think there are some there
are some deep tensions there and
particularly in terms of how how
disruptive technology is to to long-held
social norms
um that that really need to be taken out
and shaken considerably more
I can't leave it like that
once shaken what should what are you
thinking the result of that ought to be
I honestly don't know honestly you know
I think between the between the kind of
agrarian distributists and the space
fascists you know I don't know who's
going to win
um
why are the space fascist is it why is
colonizing Mars such a such a dangerous
idea for you
it's a dangerous idea I think it's
I don't even want to get into this
people get people get very wound up
about the idea
um it is called trigonometry
um I I think it's a category error I
mean we're going to get into very
metaphysical territory in a moment
um I I think trying physically to
colonize Mars is just is looking at the
whole thing completely wrong
[Laughter]
we should colonize a metaphysically yes
how was that what would that look like
um yeah I think physically trying to go
and go into space is is looking at it
wrong I'm sorry this is going to get I'm
going to back away from this because I'm
on on the brink of just faster esoteric
you don't want to have this conversation
that's fine no no worries
Mary thank you so much for coming on the
show if people want to find your work
online if they want to get the book
where is the best place to do that um is
the book is published by Forum press
um you can you'll be able to find your
way to it via my sub stack which is
reactionrefeminist.substack.com or by
looking at my work on unheard
um or by looking me up on Twitter at
moving circles perfect mayor Harrington
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me it's an absolute pleasure
you're the first interview or rather we
are the first interview you've done for
the book which we're very honored uh
thanks for coming on and thank you for
watching and listening we will see you
very soon with another terrific
interview it won't be quite like this
but it will be equally terrific or also
all of them go out at 7 pm UK time and
for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon we'll see you on locals in a
second with some bonus questions from
you that Mary's going to answer and only
you the supporters will get to see
what's your opinion about the future of
the British and American universities
are they irredeemably woke in a way that
will undermine the teaching of Science
and Engineering uh as foundations of our
prosperity or do you think they're
salvageable
foreign
[Music]